this is really exciting to me bob
newhart off the record this is an
hour-long comedy concert
and it's kind of a special event tell us
explain to people what this
is well when i met when i made the the
button on mine the first album
in in 1960 we sent the tapes to
warner brothers records and they edited
him
and and they would like oh there's
applause we'll check that out
and uh oh there there's about two
seconds there we can take that up
so it it you know when i heard it it was
like jarring
to me but i wasn't about to complain
because it was it was a huge hit
but i thought if i ever get the chance
to do it the way i heard it in my head
that's you know as a comedian you can
understand the pauses are
sometimes as important or more important
than than the words themselves
and so uh so uh showtime approached me
and
this is 1995 and they said
what would you like to do and i said i'd
like to i'd like to re-record
hearing it the way i had heard it and
and so we recorded it and um this is a
the first time it's out uh digitally
which is
it's like a whole new world and it isn't
like the record business
you don't go into a store and buy it and
take it home or steal it
if it's required space
and and uh i mean you know you just call
up and
and the next thing you know it's it's
it's there in the house yeah it's
streaming well this is this is
it's out of the way it's the way i heard
it originally yeah
you know uh many i'm not the first
person to make this point obviously but
there's such a close connection between
uh comedy and music
and um i think you more than
more than any other comic i can think of
always
used uh the spaces
the way a really good musician a jazz
musician would use pauses and spaces
to help create the music and i believe
that that's
that's something you honed in on very
early in your career
when any everybody else was trying to
fill the space with noise
you would take these very long pauses
little stammers
and it was a very musical
well that's yeah i've always felt i felt
three things i i felt
mathematics music and comedy somehow are
all intertwined i'm not sure
exactly how and people used to say as
you know after
this interview i stammer i mean that's
the way
i talk because people would say do you
really stammer and i said yeah
because there have been there have been
comedians who
who stuttered but they didn't really
stutter they only stuttered
on stage and one of them was joe joe
frisco
you ever hear joe frisco he's very funny
i i don't i don't know joe
i didn't know about joe frisco he
stuttered
and uh they told a story about joe
frisco
he that he was standing at this flop
house in in new york
and he ran into a buddy of his who's who
was even in worse shape
financially than than joe was and
and joe said i'll tell you what you can
stay you can stay
with me but you got to climb up the the
the uh
the fire escape on you know when the
fire escapes were on the outside in the
building
he said because if they find out that i
that you're staying there they're going
to hit me with a
double occupancy yeah so the guy said
yeah joe sure so he crawls up the
outside
and and he's in joe's small apartment
and the phone rings it's a clerk
downstairs and he said
mr uh mr uh frisco we know that you uh
you have a guest and we're going to
charge you for
double the occupancy and uh joe frisco
who really stuttered
said uh oh oh oh
okay but since santa send it
send it send up another another gideon
bible
we lost sound i have no sound
i can't hear i can't hear anything i
don't can you hear me
yeah oh good oh good yeah oh good there
was a great moment there
where we're doing this obviously via
zoom and you told this punch line
and i laughed really hard but you
couldn't hear me you couldn't hear me
laughing
and you thought that i just didn't like
the joke and that you had bombed is that
true
that's right which i've been through
before
you know yeah i've never experienced
that bob so i don't know what it's like
but uh you know what you know what it is
like
what here you hear the air conditioning
yes
well i i'm quite familiar
there are times there's a phone ringing
what
bob you're not taking this interview
very seriously you're clearly not taking
this is a big deal to be on the conan
o'brien show and you're treating me with
somebody on the phone saying that gonna
laugh
no it's not
but you did for a moment there we were
talking on on the zoo
i know men don't compliment other men on
their hair but i like
i like the way you're doing your hair
thank thank you
you've always been a big supporter of my
hair
in my career well somebody has yeah
not so much my comedy but you've always
said the hair is good and that's
that's more important to me than the
comedy um you must be very anxious to
get out there and do stand-up again
i'm very anxious to get out of this
interview
[Laughter]
that's it you've done nothing but abuse
me
uh i think i've been good to you i think
i've been good to ginny and how am i
repaid with absolute scorn
uh you gotta check this out the
hour-long comedy concert
bob newhart off the record this is very
special is available to stream
digitally for the first time via streams
on all
major digital platforms and uh whether
you're an
incredible fan of comedy like myself or
just someone who wants to laugh right
now
make sure you check that out
bob thank you thank you for
for doing this always a pleasure well
please
they do insult you again you did
you did my podcast and it was an hour of
you
insulting me viciously i've never heard
my staff laugh harder
they loved it
conan it was low-hanging fruit i mean
you could you couldn't avoid it
you're saying that i leave myself open
maybe i do
maybe i do well bob uh i can't wait for
this uh
pandemic to be over you know the last
thing that happened
my last social engagement was my wife
liza and i were gonna have dinner with
you and ginny
and it was the night that they shut down
all the restaurants
in la and i've been suspicious ever
since
that you somehow you did something
to get out of that engagement that's the
the excuse we use just
and guess what it was four months before
the pandemic even hit